हुआ था नमस्कार जर्मन सीखिए हिंदी में के
नेक्स्ट एपिसोड में आपका स्वागत है अब तक
के बीच एपिसोड्स पर हमसे सारे एवं के
कंसेप्ट सीटें हैं उन्होंने कुछ * के
कंसेप्ट एक्चुली ठीक है क्योंकि जो
कंसेप्ट सिंपल पास्ट टेंस चीफ मिनिस्टर इन
कुछ लोग टू में भी कंसीडर करते हैं तो
उनको ऑलमोस्ट 2030 पर सेंड ए टू ऑलरेडी
हमने सीखा हुआ है तो आज जब यह एवं एंड कर
रहे हैं तो आज हम सीखने वाले हैं कि एवं
का जो एग्जाम फॉर्मेट होता है वह क्या है
और इसके लिए कुछ टिप्स हम आज दिखने वाले
हैं तो हमें यह कैसे देखने वाले हैं तो
सबसे पहले हम देखेंगे कि मैं यह 182 बी1
बी2 है क्या उसके बाद जब ओरल एक्जाम का
फॉर्मेट क्या होता है वह देखने वाले हैं
उसके बाद हम स्पेसिफिक A2 का सेवन का
और हम उसके चार पार्ट जो होते हैं वह
देखेंगे
कि उसके बाद हम यह एग्जाम कैसे देने होती
है वह देखेंगे और एंड मैं आपको थोड़ी सी
टिप्स दूंगा कि जिससे आप अच्छे मार्ग
इसमें इसको कर सकते हो तो और अब दूसरी बात
कि आपको अगर किसी कोई भी डाउट्स और इसमें
तो आप यह मुझे इस कमेंट बॉक्स में लिख
सकते हैं इस विंसलेट को इंडिया टाइमिंग
09:38 पीएम को मैं लाइव आने वाला हूं आपके
घर कुछ डाउट है तो मैं वहां पर वह डिस्कस
करूंगा चाहिए करते हैं शुरुआत सबसे पहले
यह 182 बी1 बी2 सी 132 है क्या है
कि प्रत्येक को सिंपल चीज है अभी जिसको
बोलना आता है कि माई नेम इज किरदार वह
बोलता है मेरे को इंग्लिश आती है और जिसने
इंग्लिश में पीएचडी की है वह भी बोलता है
मेरे को इंग्लिश आती है कम डिसाइड कैसे
करेंगे कि इंग्लिश कैसी आती
है तो उसके लिए यूरोपियन कमीशन ने क्या
किया तो उन्होंने फ्रेमवर्क बनाया है apk
फाइल मतलब क्या तो कॉमन यूरोपीय फ्रेमवर्क
आफ रेफ्रेंस बनाया उससे क्या होगा कि आपकी
कोई भी भाषाओं उसमें आपको कितनी वह आती है
उसके लिए आपको रिकॉर्ड लेंथ दी उसने उसके
6 टुकड़े किए गए 182 बी1 बी2 सी वंशी 272
मतलब क्या बेसी बी1 बी2 मतलब इंटरमीडिएट
सी1 और सी2 मतलब प्रोफिशिएंट तो मतलब क्या
किसी भी भाषा में अगर आप सेवन हो तो आप
स्पेसिफिक स्किल सेट आता है तो 5611 अगर
आप हो तो आपको अपना इंट्रोडक्शन देना आता
है छोटे-छोटे क्वेश्चंस पूछने आते हैं
छोटे-छोटे रिक्वेस्ट करने आते हैं और अगर
सामने वाला शांति से आपको बात करने को
तैयार है तो आप उस से कम्यूनिकेट कर सकते
हो यह एवं फिर वह ब्रांच का हो जर्मन का
ब्रिटेन का है
थे बीवर मतलब क्या है कि भई अब थोड़ा
अच्छे से कमेंट कर सकते हैं और अपने
ओपिनियन बता सकते हो और अगर आप सीटू और
प्रोफिशिएंट तो इसका मतलब है आप कुछ भी
बोलो इससे किसी भी स्पीड में बोलो वह आपसे
कंप्लीट कर पाएगा तो इसमें सोचने वाली
क्या बात है कि देश को यहां पर कहीं भी
ऐसा नहीं क्या कोई मैं इतना ग्रामर आफ है
तो आप सेवन हो या फिर भी वो या सीटू यह
आपके लिए 500 1000 है तो आप यह दोनों b21
हो इट ऑल डिफरेंट कि आपको लेंगवेज कितनी
समझ में आती है कि देखो कैसे जर्मन में
दर्द कैसे कितना हांडी हुए इंग्लिश में ही
नहीं उतना हार्ड इन इंग्लिश में जो
कंटीन्यूअस टेंस है वह जर्मन में ही नहीं
तो आप ऐसे नहीं कर सकते हैं ठीक
कंटीन्यूअस टेंस आता है तो यौवन तो चीज की
याद रखनी है यह जो एक 182 है वह आपकी
प्रोफिशियंसी लैंग्वेज प्रोफिशिएंसी लेवल
मेजर करते हैं ना कि आपका ग्रामर या के
के मुकाबले पर सिखाने के लिए इजी होता है
इसीलिए सारे टीचर्स ग्रामर को थोड़ा
डिवाइड करते हैं ठीक है अब यह मत है कि वह
ठीक है तो बहुत इंस्टीट्यूट जो है वह
जर्मन गवर्नमेंट की फंड ऑर्गेनाइजेशन है
वह इंटरनेशनल एक्लेम है वह बहुत सारे
कंट्रीज में के डेढ़ सौ से ज्यादा ऑफिस है
और वह जर्मन भाषा और जरूरत संस्कृति के
प्रसार में काम करती है मैं खुद सीवन तक
पहुंचे थे इंस्टीट्यूट से पढ़ा हूं और मैं
इसका बहुत बड़ा फैन क्योंकि वह सिर्फ जरूर
लैंग्वेज नहीं सिखाते वह जर्मनी के बारे
में जीवन संस्कृति के बारे में एक
है और यह तो सारे इंटरनेशनल साइंटिफिक है
वह देने का अधिकार भी उनके पास है केवल एक
हो गया था तो आप उनके कोर्स भी कर सकते हो
या आप खुद सेल्स खड़ी करके एक्स्ट्रा लेना
चाहता हूं कि कोई भी लेवल किसी भी लेवल को
झांकियां दे सकते हो
कि बॉर्डर अभी यहां पर आकर मुझे और 12 पता
चले कि जो एकदम ले सकते हैं पर गौर से
सबसे इंपोर्टेंट है सबसे ज्यादा निकले
इसलिए आवाज को इतनी की बात करेंगे तो अब
हम को पता चला कि यह कोई थे यह बात क्या
होता है अब हम लेकिन इसका एक्जाम पेटर्न
क्या है तो यह बहुत ही इंट्रेस्टिंग है
दोस्तों कि उनको अभी तक या-या था कि वह
इंग्लिश का एग्जाम है बोले तो क्या सोमवार
का पेपर लेकर आओ तुम्हारा स्पेलिंग कैसे
है उस पर सब डिफरेंट है अभी अगर आप देखोगे
तो कहीं-कहीं थोड़े से ट्वेंटी मार्क्स का
ओरल एक्जाम भी होता है पड़े नैचुरल आपको
लिखना है तो लैंग्वेज आती है यहां पर ऐसा
नहीं है सीए फर्म में यहां पर कैसा है
दुबई चारों स्किल्स है कौन-कौन से हैं
परेशान मतलब बोलना
कि श्रावण मतलब लिखना यौवन मतलब सुनना और
लेजर मतलब पढ़ना यह चारों स्किल को 20%
इक्वल वेटेज है फिर आपके इंच या सीटू जाओ
एवं को भी जाओ तो भी वही सीटों को जाओ तो
भी वह एग्जाम का फॉर्मेट थोड़ा सा बदलेगा
कि बाबा कितने मार्क्स हम बदलेंगे पासिंग
वगैरह बदलेगा फिर और हमेशा एक यही रहेगा
कि चारों इनको 20% मार की रहेगी क्लियर
सबको अब हम एवं का फॉर्मेट देख में देखते
हैं तो यह में जैसे हमने बताया चारों
स्किल से उनको ट्वेंटी फाइव पर सेंट मार्क
है यहां पर चारों स्किल है वह 15 मार्ग को
थे स्पेशल को 1556 को 15 लिजम को 15 और यह
हमको बन रहा टोटल कितना हो गया सिक्सटी
मार दो
कि अभी यह छह मार्किट में सिर्फ एवं को
क्या होता है सिर्फ और लेवल तक पर पश्चिम
होता है मतलब क्या है साथ में से 60 पर
सेंट मतलब 36 आपको आगे तो आप पास हो गए
मतलब हर्ट स्कूल में 9वीं बार करने की
जरूरत नहीं है सत्या रोटी को लेकर आपको 15
15 960 आए तो भी आप पास हो डरने की बात
नहीं है मुझे खुद इस में 98% है मैंने
कितने सारे स्टूडेंट को इसमें 90% के ऊपर
मार्क हैं हंड्रेड परसेंट तक बीमार है
सिर्फ एक क्लियर हो कि वक्त उधर पासिंग है
एक साथ पासिंग होता इसलिए मैं आपको यह
एग्जांपल दिया
है तो सिंपल है चार पार्ट हरेक में 15 15
15 15 मार्ग तो अब हम हर पॉइंट डिटेल में
देखते सबसे पहले क्या है परेशान मतलब
बोलना एकदम सिंपल है तो सबसे पहले क्या
होता है कि आपको अपने इंट्रोडक्शन में ही
होती है उसके लिए आपको यह कर दिया होता है
अच्छी तो कागज देखने की जरूरत नहीं है नेट
अपना इंट्रोडक्शन दे रखा हुआ है कि वह
मेरा किरदार है मैं यहां से आया हूं मैं
यहां पर रहता हूं मैं इंजीनियर हूं जो भी
कि इस वर्ष आपको आता है वही बोलने के लिए
एक मार्क फिर आपने जो बोला उस पर
स्पेयरिंग पूछेंगे मोड स्टार्ट है मतलब
किरदार है तो खा आधे वायर किरदार एक मात्र
और एक नंबर कुछ नहीं तुम्हारा टेलीफोन
नंबर बताओ तुम्हारे पिन कोड नंबर बताओ
उसको एक हुआ हो गई थी मार कितना सिंपल
तो नेक्स्ट जो पाठ नेक्स्ट पार्ट में क्या
होता है क्वेश्चन एंड आंसर तो क्या होता
है आपको एक टीम दी जाती है अगर आप देखोगे
इस यंत्र कल मतलब खाना-पीना थी मैं और
वर्ल्ड किया जाता है ब्रॉड मतलब रेड तो
इससे आपको जो चाहिए वह पश्चिम बनाओ वह जो
वर्ड है वह लेकर थी हमसे रेट चाहिए वह
वर्ड वह क्वेश्चन बनाओ
कि कुछ भी बना सकते हो तुम ब्रेकअप करते
हो तुम कहां खाते हुड़क क्योंकि जो तुम
कौन सा बैंक खाते हो मैं इसे बनाता हूं वन
संजीव रोड या वाहन इस टू-डू रोड दो मर्द
मिल गए थे उसे
कि इसका आंसर अगर सामने वाले में दिया इस
साल रोटा मॉनिटर एक मन खुशी मिल गए
क्वेश्चन पूछने को दो मार्क आंसर देने को
एक मार्क पति मर गया ऐसी और चीनी और कुंवर
और तीर्व 64 को दो पश्चिम 2006 एकदम सिंपल
तीसरा पार्ट तो इससे भी जाइए इसमें आपको
एक दिया होगा और इससे आपको रिक्वेस्ट
बनाना है मतलब अगर बघवा तो क्या चैनल
सब्सक्राइब जरूर या फिर क्यों नहीं
नियुक्त
कि ऐसे दो बार चित्र होंगे 2 एफ़ 2
रिक्वेस्ट 269 636 इंट्रोडक्शन स्पेलिंग
और नंबर को मार दो प्रश्न 26 दूर 2015 में
से 15 बार करें को कोई भी प्रॉब्लम नहीं
है तो
और उसके बाद हम आएंगे उनको कुछ रायपुर
मतलब क्या लिखना पर यहां पर आपको लिखना
बहुत कम है सबसे पहले धर्म के फॉर्म भरना
होता एकदम सिंपल कि अगर आप किसी वायरस
सोचो अगर किसी भी गांव में पहली बार गैर
जरूरी है तो सबसे पहले क्या करना पड़ेगा
बस का एयरपोर्ट का यार एयरपोर्ट पर या
होटल में फॉर्म भरना पड़ेगा इसकी
प्रैक्टिस वो करवाते हैं तो क्या होता है
जनरल डिफिकल्ट होता है कि तुम्हारा फ्रेंड
को ही तो है यह तुम्हारी दोस्त है वह अपना
हस्बैंड के साथ और दो बच्चों के साथ कई तो
जा रही है दो दिन दो दिन होटल में रुकने
वाली है उनको एक हिम्मत चाहिए दो रूम
चाहिए ऐसे कुछ तो होगा चार लाइन ही होंगे
और उस पर पांच आपको फिल इन द ब्लैंक्स
करने हैं कि नंबर पर हम कितने उनमें से
बच्चे कितने कितने दिन रहने वाले कब आने
वाले हैं वगैरह
को एकदम सिंपल अगर तुम्हारा बेस्ट पिछले
मुकाबले की क्लियर है तो यह पांच मार्क
एकदम फ्री है आपको ऊपर का देखकर नीचे
लिखना होता है ना इसलिए समाज सोते हैं
उनमें क्या होता है कि आपको इस लेटर लिखना
है पर एक्टिव लेटर लिखना उसका थोड़ा सा
एग्जैगरेशन है कुछ नहीं आप को लेटर लिखा
है मतलब क्या 20 से 30 वर्ड लिखने तो बीस
से तीस वर्ड मतलब कितने होंगे चार या पांच
सेंटेंस फ्रेंड इजी है और इजी करने के लिए
उन्होंने आपको तीन क्वेश्चन यह तीन
पॉइंट्स दिए होते हैं हर पॉइंट पर एक या
दो सेंटेंस लिखो एक या दो ग्रामेटिकल और
लॉजिकली करेक्ट सेंटेंस लिखो हो गया तीन
पॉइंट्स हर पॉइंट को तीन मार्क 3239
है और सिर्फ जो हम फ्रॉम इनफॉरमल लेटर में
फॉर लेकर मैं आप लिखते हो रिस्पेक्ट कैंसर
और नीचे लिखे हुए इसमें पुली इनफॉर्मल
लेटर में लिखते हुए डिअर व्हाट एवर और
नीचे लिखते हो कि फ्रंट इससे वगैरह उसके
लिए एक मार्ग है
की प्रिंट टू थ्री प्लस 110 उम्र एकदम
सिंपलेस्ट एग्जांपल देखो कितना चीज होता
है कि क्या होता है कि आपको अपडेट जाने
वाले और टूरिस्ट इन्फॉर्मेशन पर को लेटर
लिख क्या लैटर लोग शुरूआत में लोगों में
अरेस्टेड सर मैडम जो भी होता है और फिर
बोलेगा मेरा नाम की जो है पहला पॉइंट यह
देखो कि आप क्यों लेकर है दूसरा पॉइंट है
कि यह थिएटर म्यूजिक कंसर्ट के बारे में
और तीसरा फटल अट्रैक्शन तो पहले क्या
बोलोगे कि मेरा नाम सिद्धार्थ जाधव है मैं
एड्रेस में आने वाला हूं उसके बाद मुझे
एड्रेस यह सब होटल वगैरह डेकोरेट मुझे
म्यूजियम या फिर यह देखना है पर चैनल
थैंक्स आप मुझे थोड़ा सा हेल्प करोगे क्या
और तीसरा बोलोगे मुझे होटल में रहना है आप
मुझे होटल अटेंशन दोगे क्या
कि इतना सब लिया 10 मार्क
को एकदम सिंपल है तो यह हो गया 15 मातृ
दिवस समझना किया है श्रवण आप बोलते हो
इतना बड़ा 15 मार्ग पर अपने मन से सिर्फ
चार या पांच सेंटेंस लिख रहे हो क्लियर
एंड अभी आएंगे हम एक इंपोर्टेंट पार्ट पर
इसको बोलते हैं यह रन मतलब सुन्नत तो
इसमें थोड़ा सा ध्यान दीजिए क्योंकि
प्रॉब्लम क्या होता है पता है क्या एवं
एवं हो या सीटों कंसेप्ट एकदम
कि वह कुछ तो सुनाएंगे और उसको आपको यह
आंसर लिखना है पर बहुत सारे लोगों को
स्पेशली जीवन के बाद यह फ्रंट अब जाता है
क्योंकि स्पेशल अगर आप जर्मनी में नहीं हो
तो आप जर्मन ज्यादा सुनते हैं तो
इंपोर्टेंट किया है वह क्या बोलते हैं वह
सुनाई देना चाहिए क्वेश्चंस अब सिंपल रहते
क्वेश्चन तो बच्चों के होते समझा तो ही
फॉर एग्जांपल देखिए कैसे होता है कि आपको
तीन ऑप्शन दिया होता है लिखा होता है कि
घर स्नाइडर का रोल नंबर कौन सा है और
कन्वर्सेशन है से होता है आप मुझे बता
सकते हैं हेयर स्प्लेंडर कहां मिलेंगे
हर्ष नाम रौ रस ना इधर दूसरी मंजिल पर रूम
नंबर 254 तो अगर आपको दो 254 बोलना आता है
तो सीम्स वेरी इजीली आंसर ऐसे ही होगा कि
वह बैग गाड़ी नंबर 17 प्लेटफार्म नंबर 18
की जगह प्लेटफार्म नंबर 19 पर आएगी पर एक
ऑप्शन में 17 18 19 तीनों होगा तो अगर
आपको कुछ समझ में नहीं आया कि वह मीनिंग
क्या है तब तो कभी मत कि 2017 सुनवाई के
लिए सत्र है समझ रहे हैं
रुपए सुनने की प्रैक्टिस र को इस वेरी इजी
और सिंपल है पहले 616 कितने हो गए छह और
द्वारा से 15 लास्ट के पार्ट टोटल कितने
हो गए 1111 जो होते उन आपको दो बार सुनाते
हैं दो बार सुनाते हैं तो आपके लिए इसलिए
पहली बार समझ सकते हो आप क्या बोल रहे हैं
दूसरी बार आंसर लिख सकते हो दो बार सुनाते
हैं 3 आप्शन होते दो बस मत हैं 3 आप्शन
हैं सिर्फ बीच के साथ से 10 जो थे बीच के
साथ सदस्य होते हैं उनमें एक ही बार
सुनाते हैं और फिर आपको ऑप्शन दो ही रहते
हैं इट या फल सबसे इंपोर्टेंट चीज क्या है
जब का लेजर है यह और हम दोनों के टेस्ट
होंगे तब अपना लें जरूर यूरिन टेस्ट होगा
वहां पर कुछ लिखना नहीं है वहां पर सिर्फ
आपको यह भी सींस ऑब्जेक्टिव समझ रहे हो
ऐसा नहीं कि आपने क्या सुनाओ लिखो मैं
आपको सिर्फ सुनने में यह ध्यान देना आपको
एक ऐसी ही लिखना है तो दिस ऑब्जेक्टिव ऐसे
मैंने बोला 11 चीजों को दो बार सुनाएंगे
चार चीजों को एक बार
क्वेश्चन आएंगे उसमें से उक्त रेलखंड पर
लिखना है सिंपल है
है और लांस क्लूसनर जो मेरा सबसे फेवरेट
टाइम है सेवन से लेकर सिरों तक कि यहां पर
ना आपका टेस्ट मतलब इस इस real-time टेस्ट
अब इतनी मुकाबले का खर्चा उतना अच्छा है
पर वहां पर आप एंजॉय कर सकते हैं उसको
सॉल्व करना तो कैसे होता है देखते हैं
पहले 5 वर्ष नार्मल जो हम अभी तक करते हैं
पहले 5 मिनट के लिए क्या होता है अब जो
आपको एक टब पैराग्राफ दिए होते तो
छोटे-छोटे और उस पर क्वेश्चन होते हैं जो
हमने पहले किया है - अगर आप उस पर एकदम
सिंपल सिंपल क्वेश्चन होते हैं 5 मिनट के
लिए
थे सेकंड और थर्ड टाइम बहुत ही
इंट्रेस्टिंग से कम टाइम में क्या होता है
कि आपको कुछ तो करने को दिया होता है और
दो एडवर्टाइजमेंट होते हैं दो ऑप्शन होते
हैं फॉर एग्जांपल कि आपको जर्मन सीखनी है
तो दो ऑप्शन दिए हैं यह क्या है कि जर्मन
बेकरी हमारे यहां सारे जर्मन खाने के सड़क
मिलते हैं और बीच यूरोपीयन लैंग्वेज स्कूल
हमारी यह सारी यूरोपियन मशीन सिखाई जाती
हैं तो आप कहां जाओगे जर्मन बेकरी नहीं
यूरोपीयन लैंग्वेज स्कूल जाओगे प्रॉब्लम
क्या होते लोग फिर जर्मनजर्मन देखते और
आंसर दे ऐसा नहीं करता समझ के लिए फॉर
एग्जांपल अगर ऊपर देखोगे तो फ्रेगनेट 1.5
बारिश गिरने वाली और कि पहले में रेगनान
है पर वह क्या है ओपन एयर फोन शर्ट है अगर
बारिश आई तो अंदर होगी ऐसा बूंदें सेकेंड
में क्या है वेटर वेटर हैदर टीमा तो वहीं
अगर समझ लोगे तो एकदम कीजिए और इंपोर्टेंट
चीज है कि यह आंदोलन का लिटरल ट्रांसलेशन
होता है पार्टनर पर या के पन्ने की टेस्ट
नहीं आप
कि समझ में लेने की लिस्ट ए कंप्रिहेंसिव
के टेस्ट तो सारे वर्ड्स समझने की जरूरत
नहीं है पर इन वन आपको आएंगे कि जिससे आप
आंसर लिख सकते हो उसकी टेंशन मत लो कि
सारे वर्ड आपको समझने की जरूरत नहीं है
कुछ इंपोर्टेंट समझ में आए तब कुत्तिया
आंसर लिख सकते हैं यह पांच मार्केट
थर्ड तो उससे भी इंट्रेस्टिंग है कि अब
आपको आपके जर्मनी में अगर आपको रख दिया तो
आपको जो बोर्ड से वह समझ में आने होंगे
रेट इसके लिए यह टेस्ट है प्लास्टिक
एग्जांपल मेरा फेवरेट देखो अब पोस्ट आफिस
के बाहर गए पोस्ट ऑफिस में देखा तो अपनी
टेंस कब है मंडे टू फ्रंट सुबह-शाम है
सैटरडे को सिर्फ सुबह यह तो अगर आप सैटरडे
गए और वहां पर बोले कि मेरे को ब्रीफ एंड
खरीदने फैब्रिक कॉटन क्या है टमाटर सैटरडे
को आपको पोस्ट से कुछ खरीदना है खरीद
पाओगे क्या चढ़े शाम को नहीं खरीदना
वेरीफाई नहीं होता है तो आंसर क्या होगा
टॉर्च आपको हो जो वर्ल्ड हैव पता होने की
जरूरत ही नहीं है वैसे हैं कि बहुत ही
मैजिकल होता है मजा आता है मतलब ऐसे लिखा
होगा कि मैं यहां पर सिगरेट पीना मना है
और नीचे लिखा होगा वह नीचे लिखा होगा कि
आप यह सिगरेट पी सकते हो
25 सर क्या होगा फाइल पुलिस के लिए क्या
पता होना चाहिए कि मानना है को पर वोटिंग
बोलते हैं यह आपको पता होना चाहिए अगर का
बेसिक को पेमेंट क्लियर है तो इस चीज में
इंटरेस्ट है तो देखिए जैसे मैंने बोला
पांच बार के लिए क्या था और एक ग्राफ पर
आंसर दोपहर ग्राफ पर 5 मार्च 22 2012 10
मिनट लो और 5 मार्च के लिए क्या है आपको
कि वह आप एक बोर्ड लिखवा बोर्ड पर से राइट
क्लियर रोशनी को एकदम सिंपल है तो अगर आप
देखोगे तो कितना सिंपल है देखो अगर आपके
जर्मन अच्छी है यज्ञ क्यूब अंडरस्टैंड
जर्मन वेल तो क्या है पैलेस में अपने
क्वेश्चन पूछे रिक्वेस्ट पूछे अपना
इंट्रोडक्शन दे रहे थे सेकंड में एक छोटा
सा फॉर्म भरा चार या पांच सेंटेंस लिखिए
थर्ड में अपने कुछ तो सुना 15015 चीज़ें
15 वर्ष के अनुसार लीजिए और उसमें क्या एक
छोटे से दो बार ग्राफ पर आंसर दो में से
एक चूज करो और बोर्ड पर से आंसर लिखो कुछ
भी हाइट नहीं है संजय आदि हम जानते हैं कि
वह थोड़े एग्जाम है
क्वेश्चंस का मतलब क्लियर करता हूं कि लोग
आपस में क्वेश्चन होते हैं तो सबसे पहला
क्वेश्चन होता है कि भई अब डायलर ट्यून
इनटू बी1 बी2 कोई एकदम नहीं सकते हो कि
हां आप एक्सटर्नली कोई भी एग्जाम
डायरेक्टरी जाकर देख सकते हैं ऐसे नहीं की
वहीं पहले ही वनडे या फिर अ फिर भी हूं और
जो हमने आज बात कि यह जो सारे स्टार्ट
मार्ग की बात उसके जो दो पेपर है दो पेपर
से वह आपको ऑयली एग्जाम के वास्ते के पेज
पर ही मिलेंगे एक्जाम प्रिपरेशन में दो
पेपर उसके योगदान के साथ भी मिलेंगे इतने
अगर आपने किए तो बस मतलब को Format समझ
में जरूरी है 156 पेपर सॉल्व किया तो
उसमें से या ऐड से कुछ नहीं होता है तो
फॉर्मेट समझ लेना इंपोर्टेंट है हर चीज है
कि वह एग्जाम कैसे देते हैं तो आपके जो भी
आप जिस आपके जल्दी की जो सीट है वहां पर
सा कि आप सर्च कर सकते हो कि बुझा लो थैंक
यूं सर वेबसाइट पर जा सकते हो और वहां पर
आपको दिखेगा अब
है कि मतलब कब-कब एग्जाम है और उसके लिए
कैसे अप्लाई कर सकते हैं हर जगह अलग होता
है वह सब कहीं-कहीं पर आपको सिर्फ मेल
करना होता है कहीं-कहीं पर कुछ स्पेसिफिक
टाइम पर चक्की मतलब वहां पर लॉग इन करना
पड़ता है कि डिपेंड्स हर सिटी में हर जगह
डिपेंड करता है कितने दिनों एग्जाम होगी
आफ थिस वेरी करते हैं तो जितना मुझे पता
है कि आई थिंक अभी इंडिया में पुणे में
60000 कुछ पर चल रही है और अस्तर रुपए और
एक्टिंग चेयरमैन यह उस पर 120 यूरोप है यू
कैन चेक द्वारा गेहूं वेबसाइट आप सारी
इन्फॉर्मेशन पॉइंट है कि वेबसाइट पर यह
सारी मिल जाएगी
कि यह सब को
है तो पीएम में आते हैं थोड़ी सी स्टेट कि
इसमें अच्छे मार्क्स कैसे आप पा सकते हैं
ओके तो सबसे पहले और सिंपल टिप्स जो है कि
जो गए थे डिवाइटिंग उस प्रिंसिपल में
बिलीव करती है अगर आपको जर्मन लैंग्वेज
अच्छे से आती है गांव के कंसेप्ट क्लियर
है तो एग्जाम के लिए कुछ अलग करने की
जरूरत नहीं है फिर वह एवं लोहे जैसी टूल
एकदम सिंपल अगर आप ठीक से जर्मन बोल पाते
हो अगर आप ठीक से जवन सुन पाते हैं अगर आप
जरूर घंटे जर्मन पढ़ने कि आपको आदत है तो
कुछ नहीं करना पड़ेगा समझ रहे हो तो उसके
लिए आप क्या कर सकते हो तो सबसे पहले आपको
क्या अपनी थोड़ी सी वोकैबलरी अच्छी करनी
चाहिए तो उसके लिए क्या है हमने डोंगरी
डिसोल्वड मैंने आपको एक बार दिए थे और फिर
जैसे-जैसे हम सीखते गए हमने इस मानसिकता
क्वेश्चन सीटें उन्हें अपना ऑलरेडी
डिसाइडेड टो वर्ड सीटें टोटल आपको अभी तक
400 वर्ड आते हैं उसके साथ कि आपको आपकी
स्पेसिफिक कोई वर्ड चाहिए तो आप सिगरेट
डिक्शनरी कर सकते हो मैं गुड टो सी यूज
करता हूं आप कोई भी यूज कर सकते हो
क्यों नहीं बोर्ड सीख सकते हो दूसरे
इंपोर्टेंट चीज है जर्मन सुनना बहुत
इंपोर्टेंट है सबसे प्रॉब्लम क्या होता है
लोग बोलते हैं और मैंने तो इतने सारे
वर्ल्ड पड़े फिर भी मैं कोई यूरिन हार
जाता है तो इसे लाइक शेयरिंग के बाद मैंने
एक महीने से फुटबॉल की प्रैक्टिस की पर
में को क्रिकेट नहीं आता
से मिक्स Android अगर आपको क्रिकेट सीखना
है तो क्रिकेट की प्रैक्टिस करनी पड़ेगी
सिमिलर अगर आपको यह दौरान अच्छा करना है
तो यह रंग की पेंट करने पड़ेगी तो उसके
लिए क्या कर सकते हो तो मुझे जो हेल्प
करता है डेस्क जॉब भी लेकर यह जो जर्मन
गवर्नमेंट का चैनल एडवेंचर भी लाइव जर्मन
में वह सुनते रखते हुए आज तक की तरह तो
चलता रहता है हर टॉपिक उनके न्यूज़ होते
हैं पर अगर आपको लगता है कि आपके लिए वह
थोड़ा हाल नेटवर्क क्या कर सकते हो अब तक
कोई भी एक कार्टून पकड़ कोई भी एक कारण
तोड़ और वह कार्टून जर्मन में देखो मैं
खुद पेपर पिक देखता हूं क्योंकि मुझे वह
बहुत अच्छा लगता कि वह तरक्की और बनेगी
मतलब एक दिन वो आपको तारे दिखाएंगे एक दिन
आपको वह सारे अगला पॉइंट डॉक्टर के बारे
में बताएंगे तो वह क्या करेंगे 50 बुलंद
बोलेंगे और कोई तो ऐसे कलर करता होगा तो
मालन मतलब ड्रॉ करना यह आपको आनंद से याद
रह जाएगा अंधेरे कोई भी आपका कार्टून लो
कोई भी शोलू पर जगमोहन सुनने
फ्लैश लाइट्स करो यह सबसे इंपोर्टेंट है
उसके बाद इंपोर्टेंट क्या है कंसिस्टेंसी
जैसे मैंने बोला हर रोज 5 सेंटेंस अगर आप
जाकर फिर से मेरा पहला वीडियो देखोगे तो
सबसे इंपोर्टेंट क्या है कि आप हर रोज 5
सेंटेंस बनाओ जो अभी कंसेप्ट सीखिए तो
पहले दिन अगर आपने वह नहीं है तो इस चपाती
करो जब आप मोड वापसी को के तो इस कारण
चपाती इससे करो जब आप फ्यूचर टेंस देखोगे
तो इस बेल का चपाती सेट करो जहां क्वेश्चन
सी द क्वेश्चन बनाओ रिक्वेस्ट को तो
रिक्वेस्ट बनाओ पास्ट टेंस पास्ट टेंस
बनाओ के थे तो कैसे सेंटेंस बनाओ यह अगर
आप हर रोज 5 सेंटेंस करते हैं ना आपको अलग
कुछ नहीं करना पड़ेगा हर रोज पांच नए
वर्ड्स सीख तेज आप अ सिर्फ पांच में वर्ड
सीखते जाओ आप विपिन उर्फ फ़्यू डेज आपका
यह हो जाएगा
है तो मुझे आशा है कि आप सबको आजम ने
जर्मन का जो एग्जांपल तो स्ट्रक्चर देखा
वह आपको समझ में आया है जो मैंने आपको
टिप्स दिए अरेस्ट किया है कि वह
कंसिस्टेंट रहूं हर रोज 5 सेंटेंस पांच
वर्ड से ज्यादा कुछ आपको करने की जरूरत
नहीं
कि अगर आपके कोई भी डाउट्स सोएं तो नीचे
कमेंट सेक्शन में लिख दीजिए जैसे मैंने
कहा मैं वेंस्डे को 930 पीएम इंडिया टाइम
लाइव आने वाला हूं उसमें वह मैं वह डिस्कस
करने की कोशिश पूरी करूंगा मुझे आशा है कि
आपको यह एपिसोड अच्छा लगा हो हम मिलते हैं
नेक्स्ट एपिसोड में धन्यवाद